la liste des accusations est une longue
litanie de propos salaces de gestes
déplacés voire de viols dans au moins
quatre des treize dossiers évoqués par
la cour sept de ces victimes dont un
homme ont souhaité aller jusqu'à porter
plainte les autres préfèrent oublier
oublier des séances de digitaux
thérapies fantaisistes ou sous couvert
de soulager des maux de dos vos des maux
de ventre voire de lutter contre la
chute des cheveux est bien les mains du
guérisseur s'attarder davantage sur des
zones érogènes que sur des points
d'acupuncture
l'homme qui comparaît ne se démonte pas
pour autant explique être victime de
l'ignorance de ces patients et patientes
pas suffisamment préparés selon lui aux
techniques qu'il utilise est il
reconnaît néanmoins avoir eu des
rapports sexuels avec deux de ses
victimes des relations consenties a dit
il décrit comme autoritaire dominant
narcissique et plus que familier avec
les femmes il risque 20 ans de réclusion
pour le juger six jurés dont une femme
seulement